you
what's going on guys welcome to the
third part of our gap o miniseries
within our Python finance indicators and
mathematics main series where we left
off we were actually programming gap o
into Python now we want to actually plot
this gap o in Python so with that let me
open a blank and what we want to do is
copy and paste that code like that
example code basically from the link in
the description if you don't have it
sample code with empty slot click on
that and what we're going to do is copy
and paste it into our empty scripts boom
don't forget to go to the top and import
math before I forget poor matt and now
in the bottom this is where we slap the
code in so go to wherever you program
this get the capo function paste that
bad boy fix the indentation now we're
ready to roll let me put this into our
recording screen and we make the text a
little bigger alright so now what we'll
do is we're going to say instead of get
over and say gap o X gap po y equals
that since it returns two values x two
dot plot and we want to plot gap box- SP
colon again check the other videos the
charting stocks video if you want to
know why we're doing that gap boy- SP
colon and the color we're going to plot
that in his white finally PLT a white
label eclipse that was a brain for a gap
o 14 and the color will be white and
this time we do want to do
okay sorry i was reading the cook wanted
to do starbucks here so let's hope we
get output here and sure enough we did
get starbucks and yeah that's about it
looks like valid data so notably here as
prices you know increasing in its
volatility as it's like shooting up
pretty fast there this is going up then
it goes down and it kind of levels off
but it levels off at a pretty high value
don't really like this one so it's
always like trending in one way so again
we could look at another stocks you've
already seen Tesla I think of a stock
that's like just been like a boring
flatline Washington Post has been good
lately but let's look at if it ever yeah
so question can post had a pretty lazy
period a couple of times so this is a
good one to show so here where it did
like you know very little kind of
flatlined ish then it was really bald
hill here shot up lots of volatility
then again a flat line and it's kind of
flatlined again anyway pretty
interesting indicator here and pretty
interesting price for Washington Post
anyway so that is our gap o indicator so
hopefully you guys learn something new
found this interesting at least as
always thanks for watching things for
the support the subscriptions in until
next time